oh my god look who it is how are you
yeah trouble
there's no beef what do you mean we both
matching we've grown up right we both
matured oh you look much well now i mean
finally
what'd you just say i said her you know
she used to work with bow wow
the guy that you casted yes
i'm sorry this is back there that was
sheila jaffee
no this is back when i needed the role
she was bow wow's uh cause there were
counterparts and this was at a time when
he was doing the show that you didn't
want me on
that's right mr self-sabotage himself oh
okay sorry wow all right well hey hi
sorry
is setting the tone
mark i wasn't prepared for the new
ditty like
like i'm not mad at you but i wasn't
ready i wasn't ready it doesn't sound
like you're not happy with it are you
okay it doesn't sound like you're happy
with it are you hating your truth this
ain't about me
when my wife and my kids saw it they
were like completely shocked nobody knew
okay because i was like is this still a
family yeah but you're giving off like
an ill thing like you're like what was
your what are you saying i wasn't ready
what does that mean that's what i'm
saying we're not doing this today i'm
asking what does that mean
well you did you see it and were you
like oh or were you like i talked about
it
i was shook it and then i was concerned
for your well-being okay were you
traumatized how are you doing
emotionally i mean listen i wasn't
traumatized you know you gotta know it
wasn't scripted that he was supposed to
hold me like that all right okay first
of all yeah
you clearly see where my hands are
uh we did a poll we did a focus group
and we were like look mark wahlberg what
do people want right what people want to
see it came up huh
no that's not what it said
no so this is a duo i didn't know i
needed
i really enjoyed this so i have to ask
you
how does kevin fare
up against the likes of will ferrell and
ted oh don't do that wow
that's a good question because i've been
wondering this the whole goddamn time
i've been wanting to know where i stand
this whole time
well
if we put you on an apple box you'll be
standing right there that's a boom sorry
just a little hanging oh my god
no um i gotta tell you
kevin like will
are some of the kindest sweetest people
who absolutely happen to be some of the
funniest people on the planet but their
comedy comes from a nice place and they
just enjoy making people laugh
so uh
i hold this man in the highest regard
possible what does that mean
yeah what did you just say just close
behind will what's that
son of a [ __ ]
no it's hard it's hard to be willed not
well is this weird it's hard to be
willing but how does mark compare to
dwayne
my shirt just got tight all right
listen if we're going to answer the
question can i get the oil all right i
need the oil let's take the band-aid and
rip it off because the people want to
know all right if you got salt at the
end of the day take the top twist it put
the salt behind you it's going to leave
a trail right
cayenne pepper is only hot if you taste
it twice okay all right so let's get to
it you understand what i'm saying if
you're gonna walk the beat of a drummer
here's my thing are you using your hands
or sticks
right
there you go i gave it to you straight
what is that what does it mean
i mean i can't be no more honest than
that
if a pig is going oink what's his tail
look like
huh
okay
come on now he's doing something
don't make me explain it to you yeah
next question right
you